There is no place where advertising is
more relevant than in the cigarette
industry.
Brand loyalty is extremely high,
so it's important to a cigarette company
that they're the first ones that you
smoke.
It's also important to distract the
customer from the obvious fallacy and
bargain that their product will
eventually kill you.
Necessity has made these companies
masters at advertising and until 1970
when cigarette advertisements were band,
nobody was better at this advertising
than Marlboro.
Cigarette or packaging is more
recognizable,
more American,
more smoke than this one,
but Marlboro did more than just when the
advertising more with their rivals.
They changed advertising forever and how
did they do it?
Well,
when Philip Morris started the company
in 18,
47,
it was aimed at women.
It didn't work very well at first.
However,
in the 19 fifties when new studies came
out that smoking caused cancer,
many tobacco companies started to panic
and change tactics.
It was at this point that Marlboro made
a key.
They switched their advertising tactic
to men and became the first ever
lifestyle advertisers.
Okay.
Pause.
Before we go further.
It's very important that you know
exactly what lifestyle advertising looks
like.
The good news is you're already super
familiar with lifestyle advertising.
Even if you don't know it.
It is when a commercial tries to tie its
product to something else in your life,
a feeling and attribute satisfaction.
The list is endless like when an energy
drink ties itself to extreme athleticism
or a camera adventure,
a soda to happiness,
a car to love,
or a phone to more than just a phone.
Once you're familiar with the term,
you'll notice it.
The most popular and effective form of
advertising that we know of,
but it wasn't always this way.
Roll the clock back 60 years and people
had a much different idea of how to
advertise your product.
Take a look at this camel ad from the
fifties
are mild kind of cigarette smoking camel
for 20 years.
I know that mild and they really taste
great.
Yes,
cameras are so mild,
that unattached of hundreds of people
who smoked all my camels for 30 days.
Throat specialists making weekly
examinations reported not one single
case of throat irritation due to smoking
camels.
Why is this ad so unconvincing?
Well,
everything is fact and product oriented
by my thing over there thing because all
our researchers say so,
but the truth is most of us don't care
about that research.
I'm buying a pack of cigarettes to be
cool,
not because Dr.
say it's more smooth than a competitors.
So in the fifties on road changed sexes,
they also changed their advertising
strategy by selling their product as a
symbol rather than just on the merits of
its design.
They did this by creating a smoking
cowboy,
known Nathan Marlboro.
The Marlboro man was designed to be the
archetype of manliness.
He was hard working and living free.
So with that last commercial in mind,
watch this commercial and notice how
much less screen time devolver oh gets
and how the focus of the ad has shifted
away from an isolated product to
encompass a feeling upper rough,
rugged,
free life.
In other words,
they weren't just selling cigarettes,
but rather a feeling of freedom and
adventure.
And there's maybe a slight irony here
that most cowboys did not smoke at this
time,
but instead dip.
But most people didn't care.
Within one year of this campaign,
Marlboro went from owning less than one
percent of the market to being the
fourth largest cigarette company in the
world.
And within four more years it became the
number one selling cigarette in the
world.
And it remains that way.
To this day,
the Marlboro man is a legend in
advertising and shape the future of
advertising forever.
And I think no matter what your stance
on cigarettes are,
we can all learn from our lessons to
help us communicate with others.
People don't want to be sold a product.
People want to be sort of feeling a
connection,
something that's worth more than the
paper that it's printed on.
So it's in the spirit of learning that I
decided to change my subscribers segment
for this video to be a little more
lifestyle oriented.